all right two years ago
americans from all over this country
went to the polls
they cast their ballots for donald j
trump
virtually all the political pundits and
analysts so-called journalists
pollsters they predicted a huge win for
hillary
they were all dead wrong americans the
voters you shocked the world and ever
since
while the trump agenda has been paying
massive dividends in just two short
years
the economy is booming 4.5 million new
jobs
4.3 million fewer americans on food
stamps
four million americans lifted out of
poverty on the manufacturing front
obama said these jobs are never coming
back four hundred thousand new jobs
unemployment claims are at a 49-year low
in just two years
we are seeing record low unemployment
for african-americans hispanic americans
asian-americans historic unemployment
for women in the workplace these are all
records and for military veterans
and for youth unemployment median
household income is now hitting
record highs 4.2 percent gdp growth in
the second quarter
3.5 in the most recent quarter and this
all comes as president trump
slash regulations promises made promises
kept
it comes after he signed the single
biggest middle
class tax cut in american history a
promise made
a promise kept he opened up american
energy
now literally we're on a path towards
energy independence
green lighting the drilling in anwar the
keystone pipeline the dakota access
pipeline
a promise made a promise kept
negotiating new trade deals in europe
renegotiating nafta pulled us out of the
job-killing paris accord
promises made promises kept in two short
years
he's led with peace through strength
abroad he has pulled us out of the
one-sided ridiculous insanity
of the nuclear deal we are no longer
dropping cargo planes of cash
on a tarmac for radical mueller's death
to america
addressing the looming crisis in north
korea keeping the promise so many other
presidents
made he's the only one to keep this
promise of moving the embassy
in jerusalem in israel to jerusalem
promises made
promise is kept and despite being out of
office for two years
this is the joke of all jokes watching
obama this weekend
obama with the worst record of any
president in modern history which i will
point out
he's now trying to take credit for
trump's success watch this
so so when you hear all this talk about
economic miracles right now
remember who started it
remember who started it
um let's remind you the voters what his
actual record is
because it's humiliating and it's
embarrassing
eight years of obama 13 million more
americans were on food stamps
8 million more americans in poverty the
lowest labor participation rate since
the 70s
the worst recovery since the 40s the
lowest homeownership rate in 51 years
get this he was the only president in
u.s history
never to experience 3 gdp growth in a
single year of his presidency oh and the
guy that claimed
nine trillion dollars in debt oh that's
irresponsible
and unpatriotic in eight years of obama
he took on
more debt than every other president
before him combined
that was two years ago today president
trump has been making a final pitch
to voters in an op-ed on fox news and
the message is clear
if you want more safety and security and
prosperity
prosperity for the american people from
all walks of life
this is about continuing the progress
voting republican
the democrats we know they have no plan
to make your life better
safer more prosperous eight years under
obama was a disaster
so instead what have we been witnessing
democrats
have some pretty extreme ulterior
motives
i have been sounding the alarm about
this for months right here on this show
when democrats tell you what their plans
are believe them
maxine waters she keeps saying in page
45 and peach 45
reclaiming my time and by the way our
fellow democrats keep saying maxine
just don't tell them we'll do it but
just don't tell them keep quiet
keep it a secret remember this
i'm in this fight i'm in this fight and
i'm not gonna move
and as you know there's a difference in
how some of our leadership talk about
how we should handle all of this
they say maxine please don't say
impeachment anymore
and when they say that i say impeachment
impeach me
now that's coming from a congresswoman
who will likely chair
a very powerful house committee
if the democrats regain power and by the
way she
adam shifty the liar shift oh they're
bragging about their plans to initiate
endless house investigations into
so-called russia collusion we've had two
years of this nonsense
the chair of the all powerful intel
committee
watch the liar shifty shift take a look
while the republicans walked away from
the investigation
the democratic minority has continued
and we've been bringing witnesses in
we've been learning more and that work
won't stop when we take the majority but
we will be able to get answers the
republicans
were unwilling to pursue records that
the republicans wouldn't ask for
the question though that i don't know
whether butler has been able to answer
because i don't know whether he's been
given the license to look
into it is were the russians laundering
money through the trump organization
and that will be a very high priority to
get an answer to
for the reason that if they were doing
this
it's not only a crime but it's something
provable
something that the russians could hold
over the head of the president united
states
never ends it's the same it's like on a
on a rewind never ends a loop democrats
what do they want they want endless
investigations
into a farce they don't want to
investigate hillary the one that paid
for phony russian lies
that led to oh lying to fisa court
judges and committing
you know obviously a fraud on the court
oh and then
leaking that information so they can get
a special counsel they don't care about
that they only care about oh if it
involves president trump
they want to impeach investigate the
president and
if you want to vote for democrats
tomorrow you're voting to raise your
taxes
remember nancy pelosi largest tax cut in
american history
literally 90 percent of working
americans benefit
and you saw what they were willing to do
to justice kavanaugh
you want higher taxes you want the lies
said about a
a man that was literally smeared and
slandered and besmirched with no
due process no presumption of innocence
they will block all judicial
appointments
by the way remember the great promise
keep your doctor
keep your plan and pay less what a lie
it's the biggest lie ever told by any
one party and now they're literally
trying to campaign
on that lie oh they want to preserve
obamacare forever
that's what's at stake tomorrow they
want to bring back the
the mandate tax that president trump and
the republicans killed
they couldn't care less if your premiums
continue to skyrocket
for them it's about power look at the
issue of immigration
they're told by the center for american
progress don't talk about it
oh change the topic but we know what
they want open borders sanctuary cities
sanctuary states
to abolish ice and once again they are
hiding their agenda from the american
people
center for american progress the think
tank of john podesta
oh just change the topic as quickly as
you possibly can
and by the way democrats they're
literally
listening because their radical
positions are so unpopular they can't
even run on what they truly believe
that's the modern democratic party this
is your choice tonight
is this what you want because that's the
agenda of nancy pelosi
that's the agenda of chuck schumer you
vote for any house democrat you're
voting for pelosi you vote for any
senate democrat you are voting for chuck
schumer
everything at this hour tonight is up
for grabs but the good news
is you have the power tonight we are
working on
three different scenarios just so you
know scenario one
republicans maintain the majority in the
house gain seats in the senate
and guess what that's a huge win
republican
option number two it's a split decision
that would be republicans losing the
house gaining seats in the senate
worst case scenario which you know we'll
let the fake news guys over there talk
about
would be republicans losing the house
and senate that would mean
wednesday morning you hear speaker elect
pelosi
senate majority elect chuck schumer in
the house
there's literally about 36 toss-ups that
will decide whether or not nancy pelosi
gets that gavel back now these are
incredibly
close important races look at them on
your screen
we also have them on hannity.com
literally states like california
minnesota
new york new jersey virginia everywhere
in between
all 435 seats matter historically a
sitting president
almost always sees losses in the house
look at this number
in 2010 the first midterm of barack
hussein
obama democrats lost 63 seats
oh but he was elected two years later
1994 bill clinton
democrats lost 54 seats and for the
first time in 40 years
leading the way by newt gingrich the
republicans took back the house of
representatives
both of them obama and clinton two years
after those disasters midterms
went on to win re-election two years
later
over in the senate we are watching a
handful of very close races that will
determine
whether or not chuck schumer becomes the
majority leader right here where we are
tonight in missouri
we are right now republican josh hawley
who will join us
is polling well he's up against liberal
radical
leftist incumbent claire mccaskill far
left senator
who's trying to convince the good people
of missouri that she's a moderate
we know that's not true don't forget she
voted against kavanaugh she voted
against neil gorsuch
she voted against the tax cuts for the
people of missouri her campaign caught
on tape
literally supporting widespread gun
restrictions and gun bans
but she's not telling the people of
missouri that arizona i can't even
believe we're talking about this race
republican american hero martha mcsally
multiple tours of duty six in iraq and
afghanistan 28 years of service
while mcsally was serving her country
abroad her opponent
radical leftist democrat kristen cinema
organizing events with the radical since
indicted
lawyer for the blind shake leading
anti-war protest in a pink tutu
with a group of witches and i'm not
making that up she was making the case
for
oh it's okay if americans want to fight
with the taliban
and as this weekend she stood by that
stupidity
those are our enemies and she called
arizonans crazy
the meth lab a democracy but they're
only crazy in a lindsay lohan way
we go to the state of indiana toss-up
tonight between mike braun and democrat
incumbent
well schumer wannabe disciple joe
donnelly
according to reports donnelly has funded
shadow efforts to fund ads
for the third party libertarian in that
race he can't win without the
libertarian of that race
dirty politics at its worst and one more
reminder by the way
that a vote for a libertarian in indiana
is a vote for donnelly and schumer
in montana this is a state that is now
in play
republican matt rosendale gaining ground
against
schumer democratic incumbent john tester
in the latest poll tester
down by three 50 percent of the state
voted it will all depend on turnout
tomorrow remember people in montana
tester voted with schumer 87
of the time you might as well have
schumer in tennessee
a very important race republican senate
candidate marcia blackburn
should win you're in tennessee tonight
take nothing for granted
anything can happen in nevada races are
always close
republican senator dean heller in a must
hold seat for the republicans
now we're going to have an actual race
on our hands in west virginia that's
news tonight
between incumbent democrat joe manchin
republican
patrick morrissey and in florida let me
just be blunt
everything in florida is as usual too
close to call
democratic do nothing schumer democrat
bill nelson
against the florida governor rick scott
who has been there again and again for
the people of florida
in florida the gubernatorial race also
so tight between ron desantis
and corrupt socialist by the way
wouldn't it be
great if we could get from an fbi
you know investigator free tickets to
hamilton and free vacations like gillum
and the worst crime rate in all of
florida republicans
by the way you guys like elton john
just checking we need a massive turnout
it's all about turnout tomorrow that's
all it is
you will get we'll get the government we
deserve we're keeping our eyes also on a
potential shocker of all places believe
it or not in new
jersey polls between corruption plague
democrat bob menendez republican
bob hugin uh marine semper fi bob
well guess what closer than anybody
predicted and in the great state of
texas
ted cruz has and has maintained a steady
lead against
bozo o'rourke even though this democrat
has literally almost gotten a hundred
million dollars
to throw at the greatest
constitutionalist in the u.s
senate texas don't let somebody that
doesn't have texas values
win texas ted cruz needs to be back in
the u.s senate
tomorrow's vote will be crucial
democrats across the country
benefiting i'm looking right over there
all over the earth
fake news the mainstream media the
biggest donors to the democratic party
they speak with one voice at this point
and say the most
hateful disgusting despicable anti-trump
vitriol
that this country frankly has ever seen
they have been worse than ever
and we've got the tape to prove it take
a look
if trump wins he will cast it as a
complete endorsement
of his most undemocratic behavior if
you're 18
and that happens you stand a very real
chance of not living in a western-style
democracy for part or all of your life
he is a racist pig he is talking about
white supremacist ideology
we are not only on a slippery we're not
on a dangerous slippery slope we're
falling
if you had a kid that had a's and b's on
their report card
uh doing well with their trumpet lessons
but also having to be selling
meth out of the basement you would say
hold on a second i can't just talk about
the good stuff i've got a problem with
this kid
racism xenophobia all these things that
i thought were already stigmatized but
donald trump has brought them out of the
closet brought them out into the open
he's using them for his political
advantage
what donald trump did was normalize
racism he
he normalized racist overtly racist
behavior
how despicable on saturday night live
one so-called comedian
making fun of republican congressional
candidate dan crenshaw
oh a hero who lost his eye
while serving our great country as a
navy seal
in afghanistan by the way all of you on
saturday night live can go straight to
hell over this
you owe this man a profuse apology
take a look dan crenshaw
oh come on man hold on
uh you may be surprised to hear he's a
congressional candidate from texas
and not a hitman in a porno movie
i'm sorry i know he lost his eye in war
or whatever
what jackasses honestly that crossed the
line
way beyond it they owe him a massive
apology
dan crenshaw to his credit he's taking
the high road he's not demanding a phony
apology
which is what it would be anyway and
tonight he represents everything that's
great
about this country everything great
about the american people
we're here in missouri and cape
girardeau the people that work hard play
by the rules pay their taxes raise their
kids obey the laws
and frankly get left behind by corrupt
government
where politicians they just want their
power finally
government has been working for the
forgotten men and women of this country
like the left by the way you know what
he's not playing the politics of
victimization
he won't give in to the gutter level
attacks of nbc
are you proud of that tom brokaw where's
tom brokaw speaking out about this
where's anybody at fake news conspiracy
tv msnbc
are you going to vilify those disgusting
remarks
you don't have the courage to speak out
and while democrats call
every conservative as i told you racist
sexist xenophobic misogynist homophobic
islamophobic dirty air dirty water oh
throw granny over the cliff and kill
children they do it every two years
every four years you ask yourself which
side are you on
the side of the decorated principled war
heroes
like martha mcsally and dan crenshaw i
know the people in cape girardeau are
are you on the side of those who support
tax cuts lowering regulations
support what has now been an economic
boom we had not seen
in over 10 years you want secure borders
you want a wall with a door and demand
that we respect our sovereignty our
borders
that people come in legally do you want
to end the policies of sanctuary cities
and sanctuary states
do you believe in peace through strength
do you value due process
do you value the presumption of
innocence do you love our constitution
our american values that made this
country so great
the people that make this country great
or do you support those on the left
do nothing but smear slander besmirch
name call plot political revenge
obstruct the president's agenda they
have no plan to make your life better
an attempt day after day hour after hour
to divide this country
any way they can today at multiple
campaign stops president trump
highlighted
what is a clear choice and contrast
between the
parties and the vision for this future
and he made his final pitch
which he'll be making right after this
show tonight to voters let's take a look
everything we have created and achieved
is at stake on election day it is if the
radical democrats take power
they will take a wrecking ball to our
economy
and to our future the democrat agenda
is a socialist nightmare for our country
the republican agenda is the american
dream and that's what we're doing we're
bringing back
the american dream they want to raise
your taxes the democrats do
restore crippling regulations shut down
your new steel mills
take away your health care and put
illegal aliens before american citizens
that's what they want
democrats are inviting caravan after
caravan of illegal aliens
to pour into our country overwhelming
your schools
your hospitals and your communities
there's only one way to stop this
democrat-led assault
on america's sovereignty you have to
vote
republican tomorrow you have to
i am asking every citizen from every
party
every background and every race color
and creed to reject the democrat
politics of anger and division
and to unite behind our proud and
righteous
destiny as americans all together
[Applause]
in just a few short hours you
have the power to shock
the world again by the way just think of
what it's going to be like
to watch the corrupt media if you do it
again
they will lose their minds